this is why president Trump is using
this campaign line which is I think one
of his most effective ones he says look
they're not come after me they're coming
after you they're not indicting me
they're indicting you you know they're
not indicting me they're indicting you I
just happen to be standing in their way
that's all it is what you're witnessing
is a continuation of the single greatest
Witch Hunt of all time
this is prosecutorial misconduct and his
primary purpose is to steal another
election
they're all
in a very coordinated attack trying to
take away our election of 2024 they
rigged the presidential election of 2020
we're not going to allow them to rig the
presidential election of 2024. it's a
great line he's tested this out before
and it's true even if you hate the guy I
think you have to recognize the line is
true